celebrating 11 years of the five again
because someone wasn't here yesterday
and he's mad he was left out so we're
doing it even bigger and better for greg
greg
we have props for you
what is that ribs ribs those are amazing
you guys see the cake here can we put
this up so everybody at home where are
these ribs from greg
it's just uh it looks like that from the
back right there king walk downtown
i could tell but you know you slice them
up
do you slice these up
i've never had these before you're
eating ribs with a fork well i have to
because i got i got to do a show oh
jesse watch watch your thumb you got the
blue frosting this is how you do it i
don't want anything celebrated i've been
eating so much on this show
what did you say nothing
all right this show's historic run
wouldn't be the same without the man the
myth the unicorn loving legend we all
know is greg gutfeld look at those packs
from his humble beginnings as the show's
coffee boy and fitness trainer
to his total dominance as the king of
late nights slaying all the liberal
late-night competitions
all right are you getting enough
attention now yes okay
i know
i know it's amazing yeah you can't
inhale them greg it's not nitrous i
[Laughter]
do we have any more of the footage of
the people that said all the nice things
about greg yesterday while he wasn't
here on the uh was there any footage of
people who said nice things about it or
anything i didn't hear anything anyway
no
this is for me i get to say something
we should thank all the fans this show
is like amazing it's amazing
every year it just keeps getting better
and better and better we get larger and
larger and even it's amazing people that
hate
our side of politics still love the show
yeah that's because we're real people
and we talk about real stuff and we and
we uh we act like real people real funny
we're yeah we're funny and you're
strange oh stop it are you finished your
unicorn lover animals are great the
whole thing you came up with that yes i
did we have some more in store for you
can we oh yeah
we do let's hear it
i'm greg
it's five o'clock in new york city and
that hath is greg's can we just take a
month or two to contemplate him the way
we might contemplate a painting by
vermeer
this looks like i have a medical
disorder this book is doing great by the
way if you haven't purchased it yet you
haven't bought my book you're dead to me
it's the gutfeld monologues i got a gift
for every one of you and i forgot to
sign them i've been carrying this show
forever oh
jessie and i are no longer friends
no longer
because if
if you do not like how soon is now by
the smiths you're not even a human being
the thing is they wanted to do an early
morning shoot
i'm not getting up for anything this
isn't fox and friends there's only one
person oh
newsway carol did your monologue on it
i'm sorry at least i know some people
don't watch my show here
[Laughter]
speaking of progress
i passed my driver's test
since i'm alone all the in the studio i
needed somebody to keep me company who
better than my little friend abe because
i love you america one more thing is up
next
animals
are great
i always wanted to have a kids program a
lot like you jesse
comes in late in the day barely does any
work
this is not right this is david this is
okay did you just burp to injuries
i got a p i got
[Music]
[Applause]
i did not know i was on air you did too
i swear on my mother he sings all the
time i sing all the time and i was like
i didn't i just didn't even i was
sitting there i turned off the the thing
and that remote thing and i just wasn't
paying any attention oh my gosh yes
shouldn't and i had to pee should i
throw this cake at gunfield's face
before should i should i do it
i love how you there's a knife right
there too yeah
oh my god all right greg i'm happy
you're happy i'm happy and we're happy
for you thank you and we love you thank
you
and you know what every day i learned
something from you greg
about controlled substances
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now